let's turn to australia where tennis
superstar novak djokovic is out of
detention after a judge ruled he can
have a visa allowing him to play in the
upcoming australian open
the judge agreed that organizers gave
the world's number one tennis player a
proper medical exemption to the
country's coveted laws roxanna siberia
reports on the decision that could still
be overruled by immigration officials
fans of the world's top men's tennis
star erupted into cheers moments after
his legal victory
after an hours-long remote hearing the
judge swiftly ordered the government to
restore novak djokovic's visa which it
had canceled when he landed
according to a transcript djokovic had
told a border official he wasn't
vaccinated and that quote they've
allowed to have the medical exemption
for the coveted vaccination i applied
they approved i just really don't know
what else do you want me to say
the judge appeared to agree asking what
more could this man have done the
government had argued prior infection is
not a valid reason to delay vaccination
rules
are rules
and there are no special cases
the possibility that djokovic may be
playing by different rules outraged some
australians who have lived under some of
the world's toughest coveted
restrictions
adding to the controversy djokovic said
he'd tested positive on december 16th
though he appeared unmasked at events in
the following days
how well do you think he's going to play
after all this he's going to be very
angry very fired up he's going to to
want to win and he always performs very
well in australia but djokovic might not
even get to that stage the serbian
athlete may still be deported the
government could decide to cancel his
visa again tomorrow the australian open
is set to begin a week from today tony
we shall see roxanna thank you very much